with about 11 million open job roles in
the United States alone organizations
are struggling to find qualified
candidates at a pace that's fast enough
and with the growth in social media and
other publicly available personal data
it's difficult to address bias in the
hiring process
so let's tackle these issues by
addressing two key questions first how
can you find candidates that have the
right skills for your job opening and
your business and second how can you
connect with these candidates in a quick
and more streamlined way well don't
worry because this is where IBM and this
way Globe will come in IBM Watson
orchestrate and this way Global combine
the power of your Watson orchestrate
digital employee or Digi with this way
Global's diversity sourcing and matching
engine so you can find qualified
candidates from a diverse talent pool
here's how it works first let's find
qualified candidates for the job
in this case the job descriptions reside
in box just select the job you need to
hire for and your Digi connects with
this way Global's candidate sourcing
technology to provide you with
potentially hundreds of matches you can
also filter for specific locations here
we're pulling candidates from Denver
Colorado through this way globals
discover service once you have your list
you can easily save the file for future
reference now you can contact the
candidates you selected using the saved
data let's encourage them to apply for
the opportunity note that the email
comes from your email address so the
message is less likely to be flagged by
spam filters you can even use custom
templates and personalize for your
audience
your Digi curates and sends the email to
your selected candidates including a
link to apply that was fast and easy
right but what about increasing the
diversity of your talent pool
traditional hiring processes can include
the evaluation of candidates based on
their social profiles this can trigger
conscious and unconscious bias may be
caused by something as simple as
someone's picture or name
this way's technology empowers your Digi
to surface diverse candidates by
redacting data that may influence biased
decisions here check out how potential
bias is redacted from the resume
screening process this is key to
delivering diverse and qualified
candidates so to wrap this up Watson
Orchestra and this way Globe will
combine the value of Digis with an
engine that can help you increase the
diversity of your talent pool and
identify qualified candidates you get
assistance from your Digi to find
qualified candidates with the right
skills for the role a streamlined way to
contact candidates and most importantly
knowing you've helped to reduce bias
during the hiring process thanks for
watching to learn more please click on
the link